Hales gonna brush my knees welcome back
to go on a break likes play some video
games ye we're starting episode 4 I'm
told the game has 5 episodes you took
the one thing let's watch another
cutscene survive dr. Emma that made you
priority one yeah they made that clear
monarch lined every escape route with
barricades roadblocks I had to get to
the mainland but I couldn't do it by car
needed a new plan yeah well can you plan
buddy I think I'm gonna need a ride
stretcher too hot here we go Aggies life
for part 1 get a good look at the
situation on the bridge I think it might
be a no-go and I'll do an outro in case
I didn't do one of I feel like this
might be in between episodes ok now we
can play a better bat bat bat bat better
look at this bottle I'm gonna kick it
look at a [ __ ] [ __ ] your bottle [ __ ] you
bottle your ground Oh what do we got
here what do we got here a cronin source
of course the cronin sauce let's go on
the hit yes oh I'm good
oh that's a nice climb buddy yeah of
course of course bet
Oh God better when you get me on that
boat monix right on my ass I'm not
exactly making friends out here how's
dr. Amer all kicking and screaming how
long bet the Pens let me check
yeah I don't [ __ ] know hey look at
this beautiful okay Bruce Who am I now
I'm Beth oh that's right Beth better get
inside before you guessed it right
got a hole next to go through here bad
but I bad do the spinner ooh I'm Jack I
do spinner ruse
well chickens law if there's a generator
we're gonna use it okay I guess not [ __ ]
it I don't [ __ ] know Oh cutscene
hello Wilder doing another sweep
good old sweep you know the sweeps that
I used to do how do they have any
[ __ ] clue where I am did they not
know I can move through time how do they
suspect they would find me I got across
the bridge
I'm looking at the bridge right now
it's getting tense out there if I go
anywhere near that thing
crossfire
who's yelling
ah let me see appear under the bridge
you should be able to meet me there at
the boat yeah that seems safe giant gas
sign out front can't miss it
you have a lot of options switching to
modern frequencies in touch soon minutes
can't Sagna don't stab me I'm Jack I
like to skip no oh I can't skip it for
some reason get to the pier how we get
down there more and more these roblox
[ __ ] eat more roblox [ __ ] roblox
bastards [ __ ] are they doing are they
beating people up that's awesome you're
hurting her why would they beat someone
up as a roadblock
alright good thing I'm the stealth mess
yep
Oh ever comes to it with that finger in
their pooper that's what they do in most
countries pros that's why I travel a lot
it feels good
first time it's weird second time what
the [ __ ] am I talking about fingering
thanks thanks colleagues protestor
you're so happy okay looks like we're
gonna have to do this stupid if I wipe
I need 45 holy in this movie money that
was awkward as hell hey a shotgun that's
convenient [ __ ] oh oh oh oh get behind
him okay [ __ ] move around okay good job
moving around buddy
idiot literally everyone should know
where I am right now
like literally everyone okay I'm wasn't
aiming at that stop dancing
stop dancing dancing hail [ __ ] change
of plans the pierced you are
sweet I'm not putting dr. Amer all at
risk
I'll make it across that bridge whatever
it takes
what I was hoping for it though cuz I
don't know I'm hard lining alright
that's what I like to call map what a
funny coincidence
no she Lily said if you had to shoot
shoot Oh what the [ __ ] are we gonna save
them are we gonna save them I loves I'm
Jack I save people has to go in it look
at this [ __ ] what the [ __ ] oh no they're
all dead they're all dead
alright cool well it should be easy to
procrastinate champ
hands up river cold you're a meanie I'm
a 13-minute dead at your feet I'll take
your gun dad and I'll take your gun and
now you're all gonna look stupid y'all
gone down there they're literally gonna
day that's awesome
I wonder if stuff like that has any
consequences Oh more fighting is about
to happen
Oh another boss what up buddy
oh that's pretty cool and nice nice an
ad in the background - that's pretty
[ __ ] cool it's still like stuck in
time alright well I know you like your
secret buddy and it's not that it's not
that difficult like to be honest you're
pretty [ __ ] embarrassing what the
[ __ ] was that
Sarah is this crotch before he dies okay
good cool
just got to make it across this dam
originally clear that looks so cool
look at that [ __ ] hey every way look at
these guys man I really did good I mean
I'm pretty awesome cool it's almost like
they knew I was coming
why don't they just drive away I'm
obviously flying getting by by my own or
or drive the boat away oh we got another
platformer hey Birds how you doing
that's cool another platform is coming I
can feel it this boat is gonna explode
Bros I'm calling it calling it right now
from Dark Souls I get that the habit of
pressing B when you go down ladders like
you're faster doesn't work
disappointment whew what's going on
well I called it nice how did this
happen
what's that [ __ ] conveniently time
freeze never mind
oh no it's taxi guy save the taxi guy
someone please taxi guy is my best
friend my best friend is taxi guy are we
stuck
oh it's another platformer
what's with boats and platformers in
this game you know it'd be real [ __ ]
nice though yeah that's right we're
gonna gonna [ __ ] him I know it again the
stutter collapse while I was in the
frozen crash oh god reach solid ground
in the deck the cargo ship was my best
bet just had to find a way down
why am i dying Harris ye whoa whoa
that's hot yeah an epic time thing okay
cool go Jack oh my god it's so [ __ ]
weird the [ __ ] is going on stuck in a
dubstep music video it might be actually
car born actually I think this is car
porn nailed add frozen crash was a mess
it's really [ __ ] subtle oh I had to
find my way across oh I am jumping on
signs and she a good an oh really there
to the truck in that what huh don't copy
me jack
I do the head we talked about this
okay oh okay
go [ __ ] yeah I was awesome this is so
cool love it
ah when will you learn what will you
learn that your actions have
consequences nailed it
I kept heading downwards towards the
cargo ship don't tell me what to do jack
I can't predict time
oh that's convenient that actually helps
me thanks about the route down
user-friendly appreciate it boat exactly
user-friendly if you know what I mean
timelines getting scrambled caught in
violent loops off sync crashing into
each other this was what the end of time
would look oh that's creepy anna-lena
everything's broken
in chaos frozen alright just gonna
scroll through here
I bet have a pipette up at that mmm at a
bap bap bap bap oh no problem I got this
did you just say come on casually as he
jumped I do that to all the time oh you
Jack your face man
hey taxi guy that's it
taxi guys still alive she was escalating
objects we're moving out of time out of
order tire time lines overlapping and it
was gonna get worse unless we could stop
it unless we could stop it press you
heard him first we go another movie
Ethan Bradberry pool you need to hand
this technology over to monarch I've
prepared for what happens next
you say you're prepared but no part of
this plan of yours involves stopping it
from happening even if I fix Williams
machine what could you possibly hope to
achieve the end of time is coming
there's no way to pay this is no bait i
jacked a ship fast board through a
[ __ ] bridge yeah that's right jack is
done he's running out and the fractures
getting worse by the minute and he
cannot be stopped
Paul has been to the end of time he's
witnessed it firsthand can't you see we
prepared for what's next out of
necessity your research is based on my
research is placing William James your
respected due respect ahem you know that
it could be fixed honor if you notice
there but I was doing Beth but they're
probably so similar that you couldn't
tell it if you stopped the cherub is
away at the fractious bears a
countermeasure hey man we're traveling
to the past to retrieve it yeah you can
help us get there faster yeah you have a
good day
or you can agree to disagree
yeah yeah you good yes I can and bad
back
I'll have to run Diagnostics on the
machine I can't promise anything before
that Beth is gonna go back time to sexy
guy hey you got it she's gonna go back
to she's the one that's gonna go back I
know it I'm bad come to the team doc
don't make sure you taxi guy do you not
have a job taxi guy hey Beth Hey Hey
before we head downstairs we have to
talk about something
okay let's talk a bit Bev charts and
plans to travel back um do some shopping
get some groceries uh okay what's up
it's about the plan Amaral gets the
machine working we go back to yesterday
and undo all of this listen in the video
will left for me he said the
countermeasure was stolen from his
workshop on July 4th 2010 he also said I
took it that means she's already done it
we have a time machine
yeah just saying we go to 2010 we steal
it if will was right that would mean it
wouldn't be a change we take the
countermeasure bring it to the present
fix the fracture save the world
okay explain to me why that's a better
plan than just going back to yesterday
and preventing all this from happening
in the first place because I'm afraid
that based on what I know about time
travel we can't change anything the past
has already happened we can't change it
but my way we don't have to yeah I don't
know I mean my plane still feels simpler
let's just get the machine working
Hach this is the guy that visited me in
the cell you may be under money Paul but
I get the impression he's not on our
side the whole time travel thing is
getting interesting time she I'm curious
what's gonna happen oh did you say
something Beth boy she looked at the
countermeasure like she's seen it before
she knows what it does what does the
countermeasure do do we know that yet
it's [ __ ] cool man
not sure I'll go check how long you need
I already found the problem quite simple
really you just have to press ctrl Alt
Delete you'll need to find a way to
reset it up there where the light is
I'll lower the ladder for you what
happened to the power power surge
occurred at 7:00 a.m. this
the machine was activated the [ __ ] does
that mean
nice Jack you did it that's not how you
ladder
what does that mean
there was a power search before we
started it the console here's got two
red lights one green you'll have to
reset the power to the two stations with
the red lights before activating the
really both stations are located above
the machine just follow the cables to
the red lights
above the machine the perfect place for
a recess which will wait
went away follow the cables that's it
how the [ __ ] do I get up there you
[ __ ] high son of a [ __ ]
okay oh I got here okay cool
if I could turn back time [ __ ] song
oh that you can go up there too that's
cool okay the first red light now green
and now I jump in sorry I was too
tempting not to try I'm so sorry that
was so unnecessary
okay here we go sorry about that I have
to go through here
what the [ __ ] who built this I mean I
know who built this but this doesn't
make any sense man I don't believe that
one guy built this
I just can't to much ever and it's too
wonky you say something you've got to be
kidding me
what is it this is all my stuff from our
family home giraffy kept everything
hated that guy huh he was an [ __ ]
not the hallway back why are you so
casual right now man my artsy rebel
phase complete with a very rebellious
how to good
I always wanted to try this actually
never at the time that time someone need
to [ __ ] make a montage of all the
time they say [ __ ] time in this
[ __ ] time
piece of [ __ ] time hey Jack come check
this out
what do you want tech CI damn are all a
hand over there yeah but I figure what
I'm doing is more important
checking your tweets I agree only me
hang in jack I got the goods okay
what is all this yeah what is it I dug
through the area and I found everything
I could on your bro you gotta see this
video I found man check out the TV and
everything else I put on those tables
over there all right time is really
interesting if you started it in physics
it's it's such a weird concept if you
think about it oh so I can't open the
door now for [ __ ] sake I'm Beth I
always keep my math epic Totoro that's
my signature
you made this I've never even been here
before
maybe she helped him build it in the
pictures you isn't so Jack there's
something you should know
1999 I was eight years old playing in my
backyard and a woman approached me told
me she's from the future she gave me
very specific details of events that
would come to pass
really she gave me this filled with
dates events proof of it all
drag that woman I hope she told you how
to win the lottery
everything I told myself would happen
did every detail for better or worse
came to pass and couldn't be changed our
fate is laid out before us jack
everything that happened to get us here
every sacrifice that was made they're
all part of this path they can't be
changed or undone
death when we step in that time machine
you will see for yourself you will see
for yourself that I am Beth
all right Beth if you're not sure about
how all this works we can try your way
how about you move from the [ __ ]
hallway Beth have you tried that looks
climbable thanks jack
they really wanted you to [ __ ] off aah
watch me go watch the parkour guy there
it is we did it
what the [ __ ] that I smoke kind of need
to kind of need to see where I'm going
right now go to the hole to the brolo
[ __ ] I can't even see where I'm going
how am I supposed to know okay let's try
that again
oh whoa whoa whoa I did it alright it's
up there no wait I didn't do the jump
properly well I might as well kill
myself what the hell am i well what the
[ __ ] Beth
this is supposed to happen this is just
[ __ ] dumb I'm walking back the entire
[ __ ] way just cuz I remember it this
is so stupid
like I can't respawn I can't [ __ ] see
where I'm going this is so dumb
so dumb this is so stupid
okay I guess I go here no I'm really not
anywhere all right all lights are green
[ __ ] you now uh mom where am i okay I
guess I'll drop down here oh no I can't
okay uh I guess I'll drop down here okay
cool
guess I'll drop down here okay cool now
we have to figure out a way to get back
okay that's cool that's cool no problem
like what the [ __ ] is this I have to
find an invisible ladder in an invisible
landscape this is great guys no heads up
either it's just like it at epithet that
there you want to you like it seeing in
your video games [ __ ] you [ __ ] you
[ __ ] in reason I can't see anything
what the [ __ ] is going on oh my god like
this [ __ ] [ __ ] part wasn't annoying
before oh my god what is this piece of
[ __ ] I can't do it I can't do it [ __ ]
awful I hated that why do they do that
why do they think that was a good idea
okay we got to make it back to that
[ __ ] I've done it once before okay
all right uh just retrace our steps I
guess
no that was there's no way for me to
know let's make a platformer where you
can't see the platform's yes
actually nevermind you can't see [ __ ]
how about that can only see where you're
walking oh oh oh I did it oh my god oh
my god
[ __ ] that that was so stupid
please let this stop it's time to stop
that fixed it come on down I don't want
to okay we're doing this I'll set the
date into the console is this a glitch
are they joking with me oh thank [ __ ]
god oh my god she's gonna turn him back
hey wait wait what the [ __ ] was that
[ __ ] what did you do that was the wrong
door
you chased a date we're up where is she
I had no choice I couldn't let you take
the countermeasure it was gray our
entire planet risk I sent her back to
1999 they're on their way it's over Rock
Shooter in the back to run the lifeboat
what did you say I'm gonna follow
through with the plan tie her up and get
as far away from here as you can yeah
I've got this don't worry Thanks taxi
guy taxi guys the best this is a random
side character of all [ __ ] time the
guy you stayed in a [ __ ] no god no
please no explore explore the swimming
hole are you [ __ ] high this can't be
real
explore the swimming hole explore the
swimming hole how oh my god slower this
good it's even trickier than before now
why did they disappear for the cutscene
why did he just come back your goal when
you arrived was to retrieve the count
like all had to wait because I wasn't
alone what just happened why is it over
no matter [ __ ] time I spent trying to
get to this [ __ ] ladder we went back
in time oh no please no is it it's a
game glitch the game is fledged the game
is glitched it must be glitch Oh what
the [ __ ] is this okay I'm getting a lock
I gotta check out that gunfire before we
go anywhere else
oh my god someone's in here it's gonna
be the guy little finger or maybe Beth
practicing firing that would make sense
I saw a gun that's the girl that died in
the beginning doesn't look like Beth
yes a girlfriend the beginning Beth oh
she's Beth what Edie
hey hey what happened you
this is it there's no turning back
Jack the whole corridor thing is so
creepy
doctor Emeril sent me to the Future I
fought for months trying to find a way
to get back
really I wasn't the only
oh really
the [ __ ]
ah
he set Williams machine to 1999 the
first possible exit point don't you
okay are you
you're the reason you built the
countermeasure then you've been here
ever since
eleven years why why didn't you come
back
we should get ready smooth deck real
some a
eleven years in a swimming hall without
water
chichi bomber and there was a weight in
her eyes she was hiding something she
hasn't seen the end of time I'll unlock
the door
so where's will where's the
countermeasure
where's taxi guy the countermeasures at
Williams workshop where you built it and
that's where we go yeah yes
what was the plan you mean that let's
just have to unlock this just have to
unwrap this I just must sing Gladys only
to get them okay fine what you don't
know that you never saw I I gave up on
the idea that she would ever come Thanks
I need to know we're still in this
together
I told you once our fate is already laid
out for us I still believe that more
than ever I'm just worried I'll take
that and that it means we finish this
you need gear take whatever you need
rest of its going in the river along
with everything else I brought here
that's a little drastic my time here is
done jack
I have to erase my presence let me know
when you're ready to go it's the kind of
measure to fix fracture so she had to
stay here to kind of like not interfere
with the time I can't imagine what
happened to you when you entered that
machine I wanted to go after you but I
didn't know where Sofia sent you or how
to find you you made it here it's all
that matters you followed the plan
whatever happened to you change it stop
we can fix this don't don't you still
don't get it can't be changed no matter
what we do the pieces fall in all of the
exact same places I've tried over and
over
I can't just sit back and do nothing you
have to let go Jack
hahahaha what is this Titanic ah sorry
hey what happened what happened what
happened I snapped what happened did you
hear me
oh that is wish don't let go Jack I was
don't let go yet Jack I've been fighting
this fight my entire life x-6 backs my
xbox froze scoot excuse me Xbox all
right bros i'm gonna have to end it
there i'm really excited to see more
about the game story is getting
interested what do you think let me know
leave a like thank you appreciate it
you're awesome stay up